it's in blue and then of course
there's the Star Trek thing yeah
yeah
I mean that's a tell me about the visor
I gotta know about device because I
gotta say to me the visor looked like a
uh there's girls in the control Booth
what are the things you put when you put
in your hair to make your hair it's not
a Barrette that's because those are the
banana clip is it what's the thing
headband thank you yeah it's like it to
me look like just a woman's headband
that threw on you that was the they
weren't was the that was the inspiration
was it it was no it wasn't it was the
inspiration it wasn't okay uh well come
really ask Michael okuda the man who who
designed it
um it was it was inspired by a Denise
okuda
um headband a women's uh hair retention
device there you okay so I'm not crazy
no you're not you're not see I was I was
just thought it was one of those things
where they were like they've spent so
much money hiring you you're you know
your your ginormous fee and and the sets
and they're like oh Jesus Christ we
forgot to do the goddamn eye thing for
it what about this
let's run a headband and like ah this
works for me off they go Fram oil filter
that's what I thought it was yeah right
didn't ever drive you berserk it you
know it it
um it became my Nemesis I'm sure
um by the first lunch break it was
exciting at first and then the the real
challenge of acting with without my eyes
um sort of landed and it was like wow
okay
um did you have a I wish I thought it
seemed like such a good idea it it
that's it it was like I was so excited
and then the reality set in it
what the hell have I gotten myself into
here because it's that I I wore an eye
patch in um Austin Powers Yeah
and that thing used to drive me bananas
because it's the depth perception thing
yes the depth and I it's kind of like
seeing a little is worse than not seeing
at all maybe yeah see did you have like
yeah upper peripheral vision no you did
not no I couldn't see above my my head I
couldn't see you couldn't see it all I
couldn't see my feet no no I could see
what was right in front of me and the
and the challenge was to not look for my
feet right
um because you know chief engineer had
to know every inch of that ship and uh
and you couldn't see me hesitating to
figure out where the you know where the
ramp was or you know I bumped into a lot
of in the first season that would
be a good behind the scenes
it was challenging it was challenging
did you have any
um apprehension about
that kind of like Star Trek being such
an iconic thing and doing a rebirth of
it or did you know this is going to be
amazing I was going to want to be a part
of it I just wanted to be a part of
course yeah I just wanted to be a part
of it and you know I I think I had um I
wasn't I wasn't afraid of it because
um overcoming The Stereotype of of Kunta
Kinte you know was was the was the job
you know that that Dolores and I
undertook
um after roots to make sure that I had a
career that that um
that had any sort of longevity in order
to do that I was going to have to you
know beat the tendency Universal wanted
to do The Life and Times of Kunta Kinte
or you know a series based on stories
and then that I just figured that was
going to be the
the end the end before just as it's
because it's beginning so was Gene
Roddenberry alive yes very much so what
was he did you meet him what was he like
very much very much he was you know he
he was that Visionary but one of the
things that I learned from Gene Gene
runberry obviously who created creator
of Star Trek they called him the big
bird of the Galaxy oh that's amazing
yeah Gene Gene taught me that all of our
heroes are human
because I did I did Revere him and then
I met him and then I and then I realized
he's a guy right yeah he was from that
generation the three martinis at lunch
and you know you look at all the first
you look at Star Trek the original Star
Trek all the women were very short
skirts he was a man of his generation
yeah yeah right so the the idea that
that that he could that both things
could be true he could be this
incredible visionary
and at the same time
um you know have have the kinds of
foibles that that most men do and that
was uh that I think that was one of the
most important lessons I've ever learned
that's a great one it is let's I'm gonna
steal that
I've got a couple people I'm gonna use
that answer on
it's a really good answer Alex Haley
taught me that your authentic voice as a
Storyteller is the only thing you've got
right develop it
develop it know who you are as the
Storyteller
right yeah and it's and that's why I
actors are just an offshoot because it's
the same thing right it's the same it's
the same thing
it's exactly the same thing now when
because I I conflate all of the Star
Treks I guess I started to get them
again at a certain point and and I go
because Whoopi is an old friend too
right and Whoopi was on and we were
talking about her time on Star Trek
right but you guys didn't did you
overlap we were in the same we were in
the same cast
um in the same cast in fact it was
Whoopi
Whoopi and I were talking because we
both shared a love for the original
track and Michelle Nichols and Star Trek
as an example of
pop culture where black people were
included yes and that was huge for for
for both of us and so she said to me I
want to be on Star Trek would you tell
Rick Berman and I did and and he didn't
believe me oh right I remember she was
the biggest star in the world I
think she just won an awesome yeah and
she wanted to do television which was
not done back in the middle no no no no
no no I mean no no there there was there
was no crossover so it was well he
doesn't give a nah she just does
what she wants why she's whooping right
that's why she's so free yeah it is yeah
she's I mean talk about following your
Muse unfettered unfettered she was just
she was just on the show and she's so
she's another one just like hugging on
Whoopi it's like she's just the best
she and Fred and Fred Rogers and and and
and and Alex uh to a certain extent I
put them in the category of most
authentic people I've ever met tell me
about Fred Rogers I never met him
um I mean obviously between the the
books and growing up with him right I I
was just fascinated that he could time
his clothing routine
in those opening credits down to the he
wrote the song so he knew how much time
he needed exactly I mean he knew he knew
exactly he knew exactly right and his
mom knitted those sweaters
people talk about Christopher Walken
having an interesting speaking Rhythm
yeah I think Fred Rogers has one of the
great speaking rhythms of all time yeah
that was it was also married with an
intentionality
um of focus he was he was laser locked
on you
when you were in his presence
and you felt the full force of his
attention which was considerable
it was probably one certainly one of the
most patient human beings I've ever met
and
openly honestly
caring and loving
as a human being because you wait
because he's so
like embedded in the public
Consciousness as Mr Rogers you keep
waiting for the other shoe to drop there
was no other there's no other shoe he
was that guy see when I first met him I
was expecting I was excited to meet the
real guy right yes because that's got to
be an act right it has to be an act yeah
that's I was red
and there's no one that that occupies
that particular space today
I mean kids are not growing up to Mr
Rogers neighborhood today unfortunately
not they just aren't
I wonder what what Mr Rogers would have
thought of tick tock
now Fred was a musician first and
foremost right so he he probably would
have he probably would have dug it do
you do a Frederick do you do any
impersonations no
I'm not a mimic
I don't I don't do Impressions I'm I'm I
Marvel at people who do because that's
that's like you know like in the Canon
of impersonations
Mr Rogers of Fred Rogers yeah
um I believe I I call him a saint he
certainly was a saintly individual I
just I'm I'm just gonna go ahead and
claim it for claim it Fred Rogers was a
saint that's so that's amazing